this is a production of Cornell
University all right well good morning
it's great to be back again after almost
a year away this morning I'll be sharing
some of the highlights of the work that
I've done as a PhD student over the last
six years these are I'll be covering
three different projects that are fairly
unrelated the first two in a little more
depth and the last one just very briefly
specifically I'll be talking about the
progress that we've done to develop
cucumbers with resistance to downy
mildew which is the most widespread and
devastating disease on cucumbers in the
US and around the world then I'll be
sharing some of the work we've been
we've done to map the major powdery
mildew resistance locust and squash
which is one of the most widely used
genes in squash breeding but which to
date didn't have any markers available
for it and lastly I'll briefly talk
about a collaborative effort we've been
doing with the USDA to develop some
genomic resources for an important USDA
peak or collection that's used by P
breeders not only in North America but
around the world so first off I'll talk
about the work we've done in cucumbers I
was really got involved in this project
from day one and this project was
started in response to an urgent need
from the cucumber industry to solve a
new disease crisis and I say new not
because downy mildew is new and
cucumbers because it had been around
since the 1800s but for many decades
growers had never really had to worry
about downy mildew at all and that's in
large part thanks to the efforts of
breeders here at Cornell and Wisconsin
and Clemson and some other places at
really developing robust disease
resistance packages in cucumber
including to downy mildew well that all
came crashing down right around 2006 and
you can see from this headline in the
American vegetable grower magazine an
old enemy reimburses suddenly growers
were seeing what too many of them was
almost a new disease
many were not really sure what it was
but it came in a very quick in dramatic
fashion so here you can see some of the
symptoms of downy mildew on cucumbers
downy mildew you'll often see downy
mildew first characterized by very
angular chlorotic lesions it's a foliar
disease so you see it on the leaves and
and those chlorotic areas eventually
coalesce and turn necrotic until you
have total plant depth and the time that
you first see a chlorotic lesion on one
leaf of a plant to the time it's
completely dead and crispy can be as
little as three weeks without any sort
of intervention so it happens really
really really quickly and in 2006 alone
it it was just cause devastating
production losses individual states were
reporting losses and tens of millions of
dollars and you know that's a pretty big
deal considering the total production
value in the u.s. is around 350 million
dollars so another reason this was such
a bad disease was that downy mildew was
present it is is areally dispersed by
asexuals Oh spores it's a gnome I see
and it can travel for hundreds of miles
so in the time in a three-week span that
your plant is dying the pathogen can
reproduce from an initial spore landing
to to producing millions of spores in 10
days those can travel in nearby plants
nearby farms and if the wind is right
hundreds or even thousands of miles away
in some cases and it's not a pathogen
that over winters in cold places but it
will overwinter in southern Florida
where they don't have a frost and it
marches up the coast as spring
temperatures get warmer which also
happens to coincide when people are
planting their cucumbers and ninety
percent of cucumber production is in
eastern states in kind of this area
where you see the downy mildew and to
an idea all of these green and blue
spots are areas that at one time or
another throughout the season reported
downy mildew and these are just the
areas where as reported pretty much you
can fill in that whole map in the
eastern US of where the disease actually
was but for a ninety percent of
production in eastern states pickling
cucumbers Michigan is a big place in
Florida North Carolina Wisconsin are
important and for slicers Florida
Georgia and North Carolina so these
places get downy mildew extremely early
in the season and then in the North
Atlantic area in the Great Lakes region
where we are we also have a one-two
punch not only from disease coming up
from the south but also from greenhouses
and hot houses that have cucumber
production all year round so there's
really no escaping this disease if you
grow cucumbers you will have done email
do on your cucumbers so not surprisingly
on 2008 there was a survey from
basically forever basically everybody
involved in the cucumber industry and
one of the questions was what can public
research institutions do and not
surprisingly downy mildew research was
ranked number one priority we need to
find fungicides we need to develop
resistance we need to develop
forecasting protocols anything related
to downy mildew so in response to that
we started a breeding program the first
thing we had to figure out was is there
any sort of acceptable resistance out
there right now so and and this was the
year before I joined so I can't take
credit for this but Michael and company
started this effort with looking at USDA
accessions looking at heirlooms going
back into the Cornell seed balls pulling
out old lines that at one time were
reported to have downy mildew resistance
and just growing really as many things
as we could with as many tips and as
much data as we could dig up and what we
found was that there were no cultivars
that had what would even approach
acceptable levels of resistance but we
did find a few
old varieties heirlooms and some of the
lines that had been developed at Cornell
in the past that had more resistance
than none they might hold on a week two
weeks three weeks longer than the most
susceptible cultivars so we decided that
was the point where we're going to start
we were going to start crossing some of
those together and see if we could
develop anything with superior
resistance and as early as 2010 we had
great promise so this is an f2
population of a cross between two of
those moderately resistant lines and
most things out in the field were dead
but every once in a while we came across
a plant that looked pretty good now in
this season we weren't to a point yet
where we had great resistance everything
died by the end of the season but you
can you can clearly see there's there's
a difference there and when we grew out
the parents individuals did much better
than the parents which indicated to us
that we were actually combining genes
from these various sources so we were on
the right track so our general breeding
strategy from that point forward was
basically to plant large populations
into heavy pathogen pressure in this
area downy mildew comes in or the downy
mildew pathogen i should say comes in
late July early August so that's when we
wanted to plant and we wanted to plant
young plants in the field so that when
we were doing disease ratings we didn't
have to worry about any complicating
effects from natural plant senescence
you know if a plant was turning the
chronic dying we knew it was from downy
mildew we harvested fruit regularly so
that we didn't have any fruit load
effects compounding resistance we piled
them by the plant so that we could get
you know a rough plant by plant yield
estimate we would flag early selections
we had harsh selection intensity at the
beginning of the program the pathogen
really did all the work for us you know
there wasn't there weren't many things
alive at the end of the season as we
increase the frequency of resistance
alleles in our population we got to the
point where everything was surviving to
the end of the season so we continued to
select the best of the best and we we
did all phenotypic selection
and found that the downy mildew
resistance was highly heritable and that
our phenotypic guys were very predictive
of the breeding value and the
performance of the lines in future years
we took cuttings there was simply no
time for Paula nations in the field
before frost so we would take cuttings
from the field and bring them into the
greenhouse to advance the generations
which was very easily done with
cucumbers you just slice off a growing
tip stick in some media make sure it
stays warm and moist and you can have
ninety percent rooting or even better
and at first we did a pedigree selection
approaches is very common in cucumber
breeding programs but then added a
recurrent selection approach with some
inter mating in the greenhouse which we
needed to capture and retain all of the
resistance alleles that we were bringing
in together because there was just too
many to capture with moderate sized
populations in the field so by 2012 we
had some lines that we were ready to
trial up top is DMR NY 264 which was our
top breeding line and below it are the
two parents so 264 stayed green all the
way till frost produce fruit all the way
till frost you can see here that it was
doing better than its parents which
would eventually die in the course of
the season and all this compared with
one of our susceptible checks piccolino
which died almost right out of the gate
and this is very typical of a lot of
cultivars that growers were growing use
whisper the words downy mildew and they
will here is 264 again with two
cultivars that were identified in the
late 2000s so some folks at North
Carolina did some trials to figure out
where was there any resistance in
cultivars they included over 80
cultivars that growers were commonly
using at the time or were historically
important and these two
made it to the top of the list so this
was the most resistant single year
multi-state cultivar and this was the
most resistant multi-year multi-state
cultivar so as you can see they're not
very good to to really highlight that
there were no options for growers at
this time so and i should say in a trial
these were not reported to be very good
either they were just the best of the
worst you know they acknowledge that
yeah these aren't very good but you know
they might survive a week longer we also
included they did another study looking
at all the USDA accessions and there was
one that stood out this P I 1970 88 that
we also included in our trial and it it
held up pretty well it had very similar
levels of resistance to some of our top
lines but resistance is about the only
thing you can say for it it's a wild
accession that was collected in India as
far as I know nobody really eats it or
would want to it's this very netted
hollow bitter fruit that is on a plant
that has a lot of sticky SAP and is
highly male and is late to flower so it
has a lot of really negative agronomic
and horticultural characteristics that
we didn't have to deal with by not using
it right out of the gate so one thing we
were really interested in is do we have
high enough level of resistance to
reduce or even avoid the use of
fungicides because this was a huge deal
for growers I have a case example here
Michigan grows 30,000 acres of cucumber
they were spending growers collectively
were spending six point four million
dollars a year on fungicide on cucurbits
most of that was for fungicides for
downy mildew and cucumber and this was
costing growers up to six hundred
dollars an acre which was completely
eliminating the probability for a lot of
them
and they really had no choice on the
fungicides they used because downy
mildew had overcome so many fungicides
they were forced to use the latest and
greatest most expensive and because it
reproduces so quickly and is so virulent
they were spraying on a weekly basis and
spraying even before the pathogen came
into the area because once you see it
you know it's game over and even with
fungicides you know they were gaining or
they are I should say you know
fungicides are still important they
gained some time and often it is enough
time to get a harvest but growers really
want something resistance that they can
add to their fungicide programs so what
we did was we did a split plot trial
where we had four coultas gens we had
two cultivars a slicer a Pickler that
are very common in production and then
we had two of our breeding lines
including 264 which is our was our top
line in one of the plots we had a no
treatment trial we didn't spray a
fungicide at all and the other one we
used what is a standard grower
application of fungicide so we sprayed
weekly alternated between two of the
most effective fungicides at the time
and what we found not surprisingly was
this is a measure of area under disease
progress curve a measure of total amount
of disease that the plants have the
higher numbers are worse you want a
lower number without any sort of
treatment dasher to and Eureka died
pretty quickly they accumulated a lot of
disease very quickly and we we still saw
some effect of using fungicide with our
lines but this top line was
statistically not different between the
fungicide and no fungicide applications
which indicated to us that growers could
use this line without in areas of
moderate pressure could use this line
without fungicide or with
reduced fungicide applications so this
was a really significant finding for us
so we released this line and it was
immediately picked up by small seed
company in the south where it really
gained traction because of the heavy
disease pressure there and the lack of
any time at all to grow cucumbers before
the disease moves into the area but it
still had some some flaws that we needed
to work on we wanted to improve
earliness we were about 10 to 15 to 64
is about 10 to 15 days later than
commercial cultivars which with
cucumbers when you're talking about a
crop that usually starts producing fruit
in about 55 days that's that's pretty
significant we wanted to improve yield
it's always a goal reduce the male
flowering it had a little bit skewed
ratio that we wanted to change and
improve the fruit size so 264 really was
a slicer in a Pickler's body it was a
small four to six inch fruit but had the
skin of a slicer so we wanted to change
that so we started crossing you know
went back to crossing 264 with some
elite lines and cultivars using the same
approach that I described earlier so as
of last year we had some new lines that
we again child and this is courtesy of
Loren who I worked with last year to set
up the trial and she took all this data
after I had left and our most promising
line 401 did extremely well in the field
here's a picture of it that we took for
a publication we now have an eight to
ten inch fruit as opposed to five to six
it has a similar disease resistance in
this first column as 264 and much better
than everything else we compared it to
and I should point out that this SV line
darlington
our cultivars that have been released by
seed companies with purported downy
mildew tolerance or resistance so we
wanted to compare our material with what
was considered the best of the mark at
the time and there was really no
comparison for the resistance the fruit
under disease pressure was much higher
than everything else and like I said it
was bigger fruit not only more but
bigger and days to harvest was right
where we wanted it to be right in line
with the other commercial cultivars so
and here you can see the plants growing
out in the field our two lines here the
Marga more 97 which kind of represents
this B group here and then straight A
which is another very susceptible
variety I was completely dead at the
time all these pictures were taken so
we've released 401 and look forward to
it being trialed by seed companies as a
line to be sold by itself or in a hybrid
and one question I get a lot is how
durable do you think the resistance is
and that's a good question that's a hard
question to answer there's some anxiety
about any new line that is produced
because this this is a really nasty
pathogen in terms of its ability to to
mutate and overcome plant host
resistance and and develop resistance to
fungicides so here's just a couple
articles that have been released since
this new strain came on board showing
new avenues for pseudo / Knott's Berry
cubensis the pathogen to mutate change
and cause infection so mostly the
pathogen is spread via asexual zou
spores but a new mating type has been
found in the US which could open the
door for sexual reproduction and
recombination that comes with that
there's different populations of the
pathogen there's a lot of genetic
variability out there
which if it starts recombining could be
very problematic we've now found
evidence of seed transmission so this is
extremely important because before you
know we could predict where is going to
be based on wind currents now it just
depends on where seed is moving
potentially and also there's been some
new hosts discovered that might actually
allow the pathogen to overwinter so it's
a problem that we still have to work on
there's still a lot of unknowns but one
of the great things about the line that
we've developed or the lines that we've
developed is that there really a
combination of resistance genes from
different sources we don't know exactly
how many we know it's more than can be
easily determined by segregation ratios
and family populations but we don't know
how many it is but it's my hope that
it's enough that if we keep working on
this we can stay ahead of the pathogen
so the next steps obviously are to
continue trialing these lines and
numerous locations development of more
commercial cultivars with Cornell
material in it we need to incorporate
resistance into other market types so
the pickling sector is actually larger
than the slicing cucumber sector in the
US and we they're also desperate for
some downy mildew resistant material and
and I know that's one thing that Lauren
is working on that you might hear about
in the future we need to continue to
improve resistance maybe by identifying
new sources of resistance such as 1970
88 could we use that does it have
different resistance genes that could be
combined with the Cornell resistance
genes to really produce almost immunity
and then depending on how many genes are
involved you know the development of
markers and either a marcus's the
selection or even a genomic selection
approach could help us more easily move
these genes into new material
so that was cucumbers now I'm going to
switch gears a little bit and talk about
the work we've done to map the powdery
mildew resistance gene p.m. 0 and
cucurbita and cucurbita is the genus of
squash and pumpkins first look at the
disease powdery mildew so powdery mildew
is a disease that can occur on a lot of
very taxonomically diverse plant species
the disease is caused by a number of
different pathogens all from the same
fungal family so we're dealing with a
fungal disease instead of an old my seat
and this is pretty common symptoms you
know it'll range depending on the
pathogen and the host but oftentimes
you'll see these white fuzzy spots on
leaves powdery mildews of foliar
pathogen and those fuzzy spots are the
signs of the pathogen of the colonies of
canadia fours which are the reproductive
structures eventually these colonies
will coalesce so that you have a fuzzy
mat on the upper leaf surface and
potentially the lower leaf surface and
in the course of infection you can often
get chlorotic areas at the point of or
nearby the colonies which is a sign of
the the pathogen using the plants
resources so it's the most prevalent
disease on squash and pumpkins like the
downy mildew pathogen it's dispersed
areally so it's pretty much everywhere
that squash and pumpkins are grown
unlike downy mildew it typically results
in slow plant death but can definitely
reduce fruit quantity quality and store
ability so it's it's really the number
one disease that squash and pumpkin
growers are asking about and talking
about so powdery mildew can occur on all
of the cultivated species that we use
and I just wanted to introduce them
because you hear me talking about these
different species
a little bit later on so one of the
species that is common in the u.s. is
curative pepo and that includes your
jack-o'-lantern pumpkins your spaghetti
squash acorn squash zucchinis summer
squash then there's cucurbit emociona
which includes your butter nuts
sometimes your cheese type pumpkins and
also processing type pumpkins so there's
the Dickinson variety among others that
are typically used to make canned
pumpkin pie filling and then there's q
Kerber to maxima which includes the
Buttercup types and your giant
award-winning pumpkins modeled by Chris
and Kyle right here you're going for a
number that beats that this year right
and once again most squash and pumpkins
are produced in eastern states about
eighty percent of the production is east
of the Mississippi River and a
production value of about 335 million
dollars so as you can imagine this is
such an important disease in squash and
pumpkins that breeders and geneticists
have been looking for a long time for
sources of resistance unfortunately
there's no known resistance native
resistance in cucurbita pepo back in the
early 1970s some researchers grew out
the whole USDA collection of all three
of these species and found nothing that
even approached acceptable resistance in
cucurbita pepo they found some moderate
resistance in both cucurbit mo showed
and maxima but it wasn't really robust
is it wasn't what would even approach
what was desired by the industry and
market place however Derek
is known to be powdery mildew resistance
in several wild comparative species and
here are some of the cute carpet of
species shown here and with this is a
crossing polygon showing what things are
sparingly compatible a line doesn't mean
it's readily compatible but it means
that if you work hard enough at it and
long enough you can often get a few
seeds from the cross so one of these
species you kerber to okeechobee ansys
here is resistant and was collected in
Mexico a long time ago and sent to
Cornell with the hope that it could be
crossed with mo chada and people to to
bring resistance in and that was
ultimately very successful after a lot
of effort resistance was transferred
from this wild gourd like plant to
cucurbit mo shotta and then eventually
into kicker bit of pipo through a most
shot abridge so it needed a little help
there but but they made it and it wasn't
complete resistance that was transferred
because we've never seen any powdery
mildew on this plant in the field it's
completely resistant in Q karamo shotta
and Pipo we don't see that and the
reason for that is that a single gene
was transferred we we now know that this
has many genes that contribute but a
very important gene was transferred p.m.
0 and that gene confers enough
resistance that growers often need
reduced growers use reduced fungicide
applications and in a moderate year of
pathogen pressure don't need any at all
so it's adequate to get them to the end
of the season and the single gene was
confirmed back in the 1970s using
segregating populations so from there at
Cornell this gene was transferred into a
lot of different materials it was
transferred into to both subspecies of
cucurbita pepo into pumpkin and these
varieties are all
names of varieties developed at Cornell
into zucchini including Romulus here
which has been the source of resistance
for a lot of the things we've done
historically in in the breeding program
I was transferred into the other
subspecies of cucurbita pepo into
straight neck squash and a corn and
delicata it it was moved into different
butternuts in Kakuma shotta a large
butternut and a smaller butternut bugle
which is you can find in a number of
seed catalogs and one interesting
cultivar that lost resistance it was
transferred into a cucurbita pepo coke
Buzzelli which is kind of like a
zucchini but later we found lost the
resistance so that'll be important in
just a minute so from from here these
were disseminated to seed companies that
use these as sources of the pm0 gene use
these or their progenitors as we shared
as the Cornell program shared along the
way and continue to be extremely
important pretty much every variety that
is powdery mildew resistant today has
its roots in these efforts and has the
pm0 gene it's an incredibly widely used
gene but a problem to date is that there
are no markers for it and one of the
reasons for that is a lot of the squash
and breeding squash and pumpkin breeding
efforts are done by small to
medium-sized companies that just don't
have the resources for mapping and
market development and actually we have
many of you might know that we host the
vegetable breeding institute field days
every year where seed company
representatives will come in and see the
resources that the Cornell breeding
programs have developed and and kind of
pitched their ideas and what they want
to see in the future and one of my
favorite things to ask them every year
was if you could pick one thing for a
public research institute
Shin to develop that would have utility
for your breeding program what would it
be and without fail every year for
squash the two answers were markers for
powdery mildew resistance and markers
for virus resistance so it was it was a
huge need that we wanted to solve right
away so we got to thinking what can we
how can how can we we map this gene
quickly without developing new
populations without waiting additional
seasons and using the germ plasm that we
already have available we have what we
termed a shared trait introgression
panel they were things that were very
diverse in very different species
subspecies and market classes what they
all had one thing in common and that was
a single gene from a wild species
so what we decided to do was we
sequenced cucurbita okeechobee ansys
subspecies martin easy I'd the original
source of the pm0 gene using genotyping
by sequencing and we also got together a
bunch of heirloom varieties in
comparative people and one in euchre
bonomo shotta things that were around
before the integration event took plat
took place things that had no chance of
having any of the wild species in them
and we genotyped these also with GBS and
then we filtered all of the markers so
that we only kept the set that had one
allele for Martin easy i and one allele
for all of the heirlooms together and
then we sequence quite a large number of
heirlooms and we anchored all of these
markers using an f2 population that was
being grown at the time the study was
done at Rupp seeds so we partnered with
them on this project and they shared
some of their day this was an inner
specific population so it was really
great for developing lots of markers
from there we genotyped the Cornell
shared integration introgression panel
that I was referring to eat earlier all
of these inbred lines inbred cultivars
that were diverse but shared something
in common and we looked across the
genome each one of these bars represents
a chromosome from 1 to 20 and we looked
at whether they had the heirloom allele
or whether they had the Martin easy I or
Okeechobee enza salil so gray is
heirloom and blue is Martin azi and you
can see the chunk of Q kurta Martin easy
I just lights right up right on linkage
group 10 so we were pretty confident
that we had found something
when we zoomed in on the region so this
is a zoomed-in pictograph on linkage
group 10 once again we have the wild
species up top we found that there was
some recombination around the area not
surprisingly you remember me talking
about the line that had resistance that
lost it was right here still had part of
the Martin AZ I introgression it just
didn't have the resistance and all of
these up here had resistance so we were
able to use that to identify a
relatively small 500 kilobase region
that we were pretty confident had the
resistance gene it had to be somewhere
in here because he's had it and it
couldn't be here because this one didn't
have the resistance so once we had this
interval we followed up with a pretty
small jiwa study but there's only so
many cultivars e are out there right now
you know since the first cultivar
started appearing in the late 1990s but
we found about 81 kokoda people
cultivars many with the PM zero
resistance in both subspecies and all
morphotypes so here you have the text on
a subspecies here is the people
subspecies and we had pumpkins zucchini
acorns delicata anything that we could
find any market type that had the
resistance gene and where we had
heirlooms that lacked it we grew them
all in the field in replicated plots and
we use petiole ratings as our phenotype
and one thing we've learned over many
years is that petiole ratings are the
easiest way to determine if something is
carrying the pm0 gene leaf leaves can
vary a little bit but almost invariably
something that is homozygous for the
resistance allele will not have any
colonies on its petiole something that
is homozygous for the susceptibility
allele will be just covered
and usually something as heterozygous
will have colonies at its base and taper
off and the tips will be clean and then
we added to other classes just to be
able to represent some sort of
intermediate phenotypes that we saw in
the field what we found was pretty clear
on linkage group 10 right over the
interval we had our peak so for those of
you not familiar with these types of
plots this is called a Manhattan plot
where the linkage groups are on bottom
and the negative log of the p-value
which represents the significance of the
allele relating to the trait or the
phenotype and so we had very significant
hit right at the interval where we
assumed the locus was at as one more
confirmation we teamed up with r up
again who did a simple binary rating on
their f2 population this was the same f2
that we use to anchor our snips and we
took four markers these two inside the
interval on these two flanking the
interval to see if they used a different
accession of okeechobee ansys if if the
pm0 gene was in that one as well and
what we see is very much what we
expected we see an additive or
incompletely dominant gene action here
where the plants the group of plants
that had were homozygous for the
susceptibility Lil's had higher disease
ratings the ones that were homozygous
for the resistance will had significant
statistically significant lower ratings
and as we moved outside of that interval
the difference in PM scores was reduced
so we did some fine mapping and narrow
that 500kb region to about a little less
than 80k kb
and we found a number of interesting
candidate genes so I've highlighted four
of them here we found a predicted
peroxidase which is known to contribute
to powdery mildew resistance in barley
there's the salicylic acid binding
protein which contributes to powdery
mildew resistance in arabidopsis this
one I think is particularly interesting
this is a an NB slrr that is a powdery
mildew resistance protein in arabidopsis
and then zinc finger there's a zinc
finger protein here and those are
involved in a lot of by atrophic
pathogen resistances so it could be any
number of these this is as far as we are
at to date it presents a lot of
interesting questions moving forward for
someone to follow up on and we
definitely don't rule out possibly
that's a number of these genes acting in
tandem it could be multiple of these or
you know in the case of the r gene it's
a very big R Gean maybe it's actually a
raft of our genes connected to each
other and so the last thing we did and
this credit goes to Kyle was to take
some of our markers and and or take some
of the snips and develop markers into
them we release the sequence information
so that those can be adapted to any
platform that the Breeders want and ran
some caps here where we had perfect
segregation between the phenotype and
the marker
so the next steps evaluate candidates to
identify the causal gene I think that'll
be a very interesting exercise we need
to continue to improve powdery mildew
resistance in commercial cultivars this
isn't directly related to what I was
talking about but it's very important as
I said the pm0 gene doesn't confer
immunity into into the tolerant
genotypes and there has been more
reports in recent years that the
resistance isn't holding up as well as
it had in the past and that's not at all
surprising we're talking about a single
gene resistance eventually that's going
to break down so we need to be on top of
finding other sources of resistance
using recurrent selection approaches to
combine these small effect alleles that
might be natively in Concordat pepo or
especially cucurbit emociona we could
also revisit some of these wild species
to pick up the genes that were left
behind in the beginning and we have a
lot more tools and technologies now to
do that then they had in the 1970s so
really briefly i'm going to talk about a
collaborative effort with the usda on
doing some genetic characterization of
what we termed the usda pison diversity
collection and this collection really
has its roots in a core collection
developed in the early 1990s that was
assembled to maximize geographical and
morphological diversity within the
collection in accessions were collected
all around the world and this map shows
the 238 accessions of the upvc as we
call it that were collected in addition
there's almost 200 accessions that were
developed by breeding programs or
donated by institutions but have unknown
collection origins and one thing one
thing in particular to note is that this
collection includes breeding material
from
the USDA and Washington State breeding
programs and field peas and snap peas
developed by Jim Meyers and his
predecessors at Oregon State so oh I
should I should say that this collection
is used widely by P breeders to find new
traits so the collections been grown out
the core collection and its derivatives
including the upvc have been grown out
in various permutations many times by
breeders looking for new traits and
there's been a lot of traits that have
been phenotypes that have been recorded
are publicly available one big thing
that was missing was any sort of high
density molecular data and this was
needed to be able to map those traits a
lot of the traits that are important in
PR single gene traits that would be
relatively simple to map with enough
markers and enough individuals the
phenotype data is already there and
another thing we wanted to do was be
able to get a genetic snapshot of what
the collection looked like oftentimes
morphett the phenotypes could look
similar but they could be very
genetically unrelated so this would help
us to to tease out where diversity is
for breeding programs so one of the
first things we did was look at the
structure of the collection and here we
have a principal components diagram
showing each one of these dots
represents an accession that was
genotyped here are the Oregon State snap
peas snap and snow peas here are the
Washington State field peas and then
these other colors were used based on
previous studies that included these
materials so this study or this color
here yellow represents
the cultivated type p pi seems to tie
them subspecies to tie them here are in
blue are they to recognize subspecies of
pi seems to tie them alaysia Senatus
inikkum and what is perhaps the most
interesting is this area of green here
so these peas here come from Central
Asia and and really all of these due to
these were just the ones that were
included in in previous studies and
these are not recognized as a separate
subspecies many people have noticed that
peas from Central Asia seem to be
different than the cultivated peas but
no one has really looked too much into
it so one of the things we were
interested in doing with the genetic
data is trying to see if we could
uncover anything about this this very
different group of peace and it should
be said that these peas are often found
in mountainous regions in Central Asia
so to think of the mountainous areas in
Iran and Afghanistan India and Nepal
they tend to be more cold tolerant they
have different they tend to be low
growing basil branching so there's a lot
of phenotypic differences as well one of
the questions we had and which hasn't
really been addressed is is it possible
that that these accessions had some
ancient or maybe more recent integration
from Pais and fulham which is the only
other sister species of pi seems to
tighten so we went to the USDA
collection and genotyped with GBS some
pipes and Fulham's to see if they
clustered near by the Central Asian peas
and those are included at red at the top
and we found out that they don't and one
of the reasons we thought they might was
because there are some phenotypic
similarities so there still is work that
needs to be done to figure out where do
these peas come from and
these these peas have a lot of genetic
diversity we looked at how much
diversity they have to offer to breeding
programs and so on the left we have each
group pais and fulham the subspecies of
leyte asst the cultivated types the
setai them and the Central Asian piece
and we looked at how many snips they
have that are unique to each of those
groups versus these groups here so we
found and we corrected for different
population sizes within each each of
these groups we found that the central
asian piece had over 6,000 snips and
this is out of six around 68,000 snips
total that were different than anything
else and when we compared that to the
breeding program peas Washington State
and Oregon State we found that they
actually had more unique alleles than
even the pison fulham and one very
important key here is that these Central
Asian peas have not really been used in
breeding efforts as far as I know
anywhere but they are fully compatible
with cultivated suit items whereas pais
and fulham is a different species and
there's a lot of crossing barriers that
exist there to bring in that diversity
so in conclusion we've developed the
first slicing cucumber with high
resistance to a new strain of downy
mildew we have resistance genes in very
diverse moderately resistant material
that we know can be combined to provide
high levels of resistance with
resistance we can reduce or eliminate
the need for fungicides we found that
this shared trait introgression panel
mapping approach is very effective and
we think it can be used a lot in
vegetable crops where this whole model
of bringing in a single gene from wild
species is very common there's been a
lot of disease resistance genes that
have been introduced
from a single wild species and we think
this approach could really illuminate
those in short order we now have markers
for p.m. 0 which is the most widely used
gene and squash and pumpkin breeding and
which a lot of seed companies have
already started implementing into their
reading pipelines we have a high-density
snip data set that's now available for
genetic characterization and hopefully
trait mapping in a very diverse
collection of p and were particularly
interested in the application of this
data to use this group of peas from
central asia for bringing an additional
diversity to two breeding programs so
there's lots of people to acknowledge
for all of these different projects i
want to say special thanks to my
graduate committee Michael and Mike Gore
and Susan and Chris smart they've been
tremendously supportive throughout the
time I've been here and I've you know
I've been able to bounce a lot of ideas
off of them and special thanks to all
the current and former members of
Missouri lab group you know as we were
figuring things out we really help each
other with various skills & expertise
co-op these are a list of co-authors who
have been very instrumental in in all of
these different studies in cucumber
squash NP the Cornell farm and
greenhouse research teams can't get
enough thanks for everything they do to
keep things going throughout the year in
the season Mary cried anger at the
vegetable breeding Institute has been
very helpful all the time answered a lot
of questions over the years we first got
started in genotyping sharon mitchell
and charlotte charya spent a lot of time
helping
get going in those directions we had
some collaborators and other
institutions as well yishun and John
Murphy and Rupp seeds that donated seeds
or resources along the way and also
thanks in large part to all the funding
that allowed us to be able to do all of
these things so that I'll take questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu